With our routes and
database in place, we can now add the
actual CRUD Functionality to our page.
Write in the appropriate SQLAlchemy
statements for the following methods.
We also need to add url_for and
redirects to our application,
when necessary.
Some of our routes need to be able to
respond to get, and post requests.
Be sure to add this functionality,
as well.
When you are done with this step,
you should have a prototype,
where all the CRUD operations
are fully functional.
This might be a time consuming iteration
to get everything working, but
I encourage you to stick with it,
and not give up.
Use the documentation on the Python
Flask in SQLAlchemy websites if
needed, as well.
Also do not hesitate to reach
out to your fellow students.